la taille idéale j'ai hâte entre son
journal oublierez longueuil j'espère
qu'elles seront chauds sociaux tels
voyages grand portable n'a fait mal aux
images sont putty des ptic romera le
très grand et le petit écho de la forêt
c'est très serré roule verrez il y à
toutes les informations à chaque
nouvelle édition on n'a jamais de
déception ça vous le découvrirez dans le
décor de nos forums
[Musique]
[Rires]
tiens tiens tiens il adorera s'ennuie
vous ne connaissez pas ils adorent
enchère téléphone au la grande isadora
de l'opéra mais elle a été très choquée
oui et moi vous mangez s'adonna belle
cinéma mais ce plus vouloir jouer à l'
ou perché 1 à 4 coins parce que je
m'ennuie il aidera sans mouiller et en
faisait part à toute la forêt seaman
louis s'est évanoui kiwi mot quasi face
pourtant on est bien ici il connut
autant à vis des cantatrices on ne
reviendrait plus passer ses week-ends
non mais lol tu veux mon cul obama
allait y est ma condition
je vais tout aussi étonnée jpy louis se
creuser la tête pour trouver une idée
étonnante libre et on va la faire jouer
au rugby hormis un sondage et b
ce serait étonnant que le nom de b et c
est ce qu un seul apte à rêver faisons
lui faire de la broderie ou des tricots
museau de ron se dit bon du oui très
coté toskala demander conseil à
mademoiselle de la cigogne vous ne riez
pas une idée étonnante
non je regrette pourtant vous êtes
intelligente c'est vrai vous avez aussi
de l'imagination
c'est vrai vous connaissez beaucoup de
choses
c'est vrai et vous ne pouvez pas étonné
qu'ils adorent à nous c'était thonon oui
et non
je m'étonne moi-même même beau
il faut creuser la cervelle il crut
avoir trouvé pile on sait bien vingt
civils et bien droit et c'est toi
ils adorent oui oui oui être toi ou être
très belle je le sais pas moi vous aimez
moi vos lois du pouzin bon tonneau vous
et tout nu oui si vous étonnez vous
restez avec nous s'il ne peut pas
épouser pal ihsanoglu parti y est parce
que tu m'a étonné fou de joie est fier
de son astuce boris couru annoncé la
bonne nouvelle à tout le monde moi être
étonné d'être étonnant vous nourrissez
temps ça m'étonnerait mois avoir décidé
chez isadora habitudes en forêt pour
toujours et vous trouvez cela étonnant
oui et qu'il a été solide et notre va
tout simplement dément guillaume à gaz
et à la voix si être l'étau du pivot
mazel il vous a jamais demandé en
mariage
hu a eu jamais pourquoi on ne voit pas
au dessus alors à longmont cherbourg il
se ne suis pas si redoutable huawei
plutôt petit médias allons allons petit
boris je ne suis pas si impressionnante
en fait moi jamais avoir passé jamais
jamais si cet automne on discutait
boscher téléphone nous avons des choses
étonnantes mais oui mais oui c'est
étonnant vin bien tout pour une
prochaine édition et tonneaux